ça
m
[Musique]
et vous
t
j'avais
avec un tapis
t
j'accepte
[Musique]
tél
non
[Musique]
ce soir ça va ça va c'est où la salle 10
fait rage aux deux compagnies de tabac à
berne
par eric holmes
comment
mam
[Musique]
j'ai publié combien de livres depuis 47
45 personnes c'était le premier procès
en france et le premier char c'est un
anniversaire ça fait c'est vrai on
aurait pu le fêter parce que j'ai fait
les 50 ans de décision c'était décembre
c'est quoi le problème petite plaquette
dessartre l'explication de l'étranger
qui de venir à apprend 47 chez sade le
procès le premier procès saad le premier
procès qui dure nuit tôt ah ouais on
vous reproche quoi exactement
outrage aux bonnes moeurs par la voie du
livre c'est la formule vous a été
l'éditeur le plus grand de france
ah oui oui on m'a privé de mes droits
civiques j'ai pas été en prison mais on
a pris vie ne doit céder ses copines ou
qui me les a fait rendre c'est sympa ah
oui oui mais médée pompidou était très
très acharnée pour les libertés georges
pompidou était le seul homme politique
français qui a vraiment essayé de mener
un combat contre la censure il a
il a invité il m'a invité à dîner il a
organisé un dîner
on était deux éditeurs lui et sa femme
d'autres c'était bourgois ses angoisses
et il nous expliquer pendant tout le
dîner qui les interdictions qu'elle fait
soit de livres s'était terminée il n'en
fallait plus il était premier ministre
en fait t'es pas un député quelconque et
moi j'ai passé le dîner à une vidéo vous
allez avoir les pires ennuis avec tout
le monde y compris avec les gens de
votre propre parti
ce qui s'est passé des yeux et là vous
publier une anthologie historique des
lectures érotiques ou lee qui essaie un
peu de recul par ça et c'est un peu de
répondre à ces interrogations qu'est ce
que pourquoi est ce que les gens ont
écrit des textes qui que nous appelons
nous et repiqué est-ce que c'était des
textes érotiques quand ils les ont
écrits tant amusé un peu tanné écrit
l'épopée de gilgamesh il ya des passages
nous se dilate quintin
c'est un passage érotique mais qu'est ce
que c'était pour amuser potanine peut
décrire sains et ils les autres de lire
c'est le premier ça c'est le premier
c'est le premier décompte avant que ce
site environ ce n'est alors là quand on
est en mai aux beautés en egypte par
exemple on n'a pas de on a pas de
repères à disons cinq siècles près on
peut dire aux 4000 ans dès qu'il ya des
textes qui ressemble à des textes à ce
que nous appelons des textes à dire des
poèmes des mythes des choses comme ça il
ya des histoires sexuelles
c'est tout de suite des histoires de
dieu et tout de suite les dieux se
sautent dessus
ou l'amour ce viol dans l'épopée de
gilgamesh très violents se passait pas
dans le cédant et musset et je sais plus
quoi il ya dieu qui viole une ds la ds
qui courent après et c'est immédiat tout
donc ça va de moins 4000 1985 et c'est
un travail de parler des gens très
connus j'ai regardé un peu là-bas il ya
des gens très connus il ya d'abord il ya
presque tous les écrits en français
parce que la france est pour une raison
alors là qui m'échappe que je pourrais
pas du tout vous dis mais c'est une
constatation que j'ai fait en
travaillant là dessus tout de même 20
ans c'est que le pain on connaît a
pratiquement 10% de ce qu'on appelle la
littérature érotique le reste a été
perdu en furie détruit enfouis oublier
plus ou moins volontairement sur ces 10
% 90 % sont français pourquoi je ne sais
pas pourquoi est ce que tous les élus
grands écrivains français pratiquement
ont écrit des textes érotiques alors que
par exemple chez les anglo saxons c'est
un sur mine si nous sur sur gimme ses 10
passes et la fréquentation de l'érotisme
qui nous a conservé comme ça parce que
moi je faisais 70 ans
oui j'espère me disent jamais vu
quelqu'un team avant pas du tout non
j'ai pas gentille c'est à dire les
bon-encontrais réputation
c'est tout à fait tout à fait ça j'ai
jamais vu ça c'est à dire que je pourrai
55 ans
merci merci quand ça fait plaisir c'est
dû à quoi
je ne sais pas ce que vous dites est en
tout cas mon anthologie m'a fait prendre
quelques kilos
oui je sais ce qu'on appelle un
justicier j ouais c'est ça ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je traite
je prenne le feu rouge passe au vert ce
trottoir quelle galère je traîne
[Musique]
je traite
je traîne un mec m'a regardé je ferai
peut-être me poser ouais
[Musique]
au bar des italiens
barret
musique sonne super
dans cet endroit désert
italien
ouais
à tous les quarts d'heure
comme moi visiteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya toi barki au compteur
du flip
à bbb
maingain
[Musique]
5 yoga blachier
et c'est le fun je suis venu c'est
valable
c'est qu'ils rien
regardez
oui beaucoup
et
le tramway need you did you
[Musique]
elle s'interrompt
sow
[Musique]
oui
et
beaucoup
[Musique]
mais ce seront
c
com
et
[Musique]
dans une nouvelle pique
balèti match que tu
tu es tu
[Musique]
l'humidité
c'est que t'as vu
une
[Musique]
pour les nerfs
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sow
et nice
[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
le porno
oui
batimat tous quoi
quand
[Musique]
we can a dit ok
et
tête 81
un saut
le fond
tu lui mets
oui
sauvée du dépôt
tu
je suis
il
à 120
le tue
[Musique]
sex and drugs and rock'n roll
et jean roba pas
pauline in check je n'ai aucun bon
était méconnu
[Musique]
m
lanoraie à johnny bench
[Musique]
sp jeunesse y est un live c'est que j'ai
beau sexe
[Musique]
car oui c'est moi j'ai fait des missions
sociales de tina kieffer l'assaut la
pollution a inspiré par les bagnoles en
ville et tout ça et puis il ya tous et
que j'ai oublié de dire semble je m'en
veux je peux dire à toi dis c'est que en
plus je sens at-elle monnaie on s'est
tellement la france vient réguler à toul
à toulouse
vous êtes petit inventeur français moyen
tout cas mis au point une perte pour les
voitures électriques ultra légères moi
je sais pas c'est des batteries des
soins de batteries la russie à face à
plat les jets et ben aucun constructeur
français nous n'avons vu tu l'as tu
oublieras la télé il a vendu aux
japonais et je voulais dire qu'à la télé
vraiment chez folle de rage parce qu'ils
avaient tous dégustent accueillir ce pas
toi j'ai un esprit d'escalier sa manière
est allé à malte finalement oui c'est la
manade jean noël tu veux bien mais on se
sont fait la bise en principe a beaucoup
travaillé ensemble
oui c'est que j'ai donné son premier
travail quand on aurait là seulement il
n'a triché toujours pas me dis que ce
sont vivants mais qu'est ce que tu veux
faire c'est de la pub alors il a pris la
fêlée l'épave
de monsieur tout cela il est devenu
réveillez-vous d'argent oui combien fait
10 millions de francs il ya 10 millions
francs qui me sont passés entre les
mains qui ordonnait universelle qui met
des six prévus c'est un voyage en
dispensant et ça c'est des 10%
et puis un pont pas loin de 60 % donc en
fait
je retrouvais avec un peu moins
en fait trois quatre et comme tu te
crois super-riches suffi au dessus de
ses moyens toute la semaine on s'y sent
à l aise comme évident moi je veux bien
il est honnête je quitte à mettre giral
c'est loupé voilà vue c'est parce
qu'elle est super sympa et faire du
cantal en scène choisissent théâtre
attention à trouver un bon restaurant
phase où on nous fait passer
voilà j'ai mélangé voilà oui en principe
à l'oignon et si c'était un carnet de
contacts tous les jours sur sept selon m
la pression s'est fait venir un triste
chine et de ce que j'ai proposé qu'on
salue on évoque mais je veux dire sans
dire qu'une gt impossibilité à croire
donc de personnes fille tu vois qu'on
fera de grandes choses un peu l'âme
culturel est là pour l'instant mes
camarades pour le centre que ce schéma
avec même la gironde
m
bon tout ça pour vous dire que donc
c'est quand même principe à caen moi ce
que j'aime c'est faire dans ce genre de
circonstances
en fait ce qui m'intéresse pas c'est le
jeu d'acteur
en titrant plus de droits
je me fais tous les sept ans
comment il est pénible ce n'est pas
brûlé quitter sa manière il bazarde plus
que moi il arrive à bavarder plus en
plus plus longtemps et plus fort que moi
c'est exactement ce soir dimanche
pourtant épargnée par la pluie commence
comme ça quand on pense aux relations de
l'homme et de la femme depuis le
néandertalien sida et bien on se rend
compte qu'en france mène et c est en
france si l'on prend ce coin de bretagne
qui la bretagne ouest sud est c'est
qu'on arrive jusqu'aux villages et
palerme avant la zone alors qu'ils se
termine par et dans la chaumière la
maison là j'ai eu de la chance dans le
fauteuil se trouve se nomme levier gamme
et sur le fond de ce noble vieillard
l'observateur attentif pourra lire que
et hop c'est parti pour la biographie du
noble vieillard 30 postes annoncées 70
veut dire moi j'adore je peux avoir
il faut pour une formation spéciale
c'est la première fois que je vois
quelqu'un à manger de la soupe à
l'oignon avec des souches expédia qui
lie son crâne selon younès qui sont en
train de faire quand même c'est un repas
auvergnats japonais s'est affinée
moi j'essaye de girolles et des sushis
[Musique]
pas trois ans d'arrêt fait parce que
déjà nous vous préparons les répètes
jambes et d'estimer la mémoire 1
non je ferais jamais de terre moi je
suis si ça commence après je parle de
fumée de cigarette
adapté c'est complètement hors des voies
la presse dans un premier temps après
je sais pas ce que tu trouves cette
soupe à l'oignon alors
l'union des trois morts et dix en rouge
avec trop alors quand est-ce que tu
viens de voir germer vous savez que
rejette défilé l'arrière de bien et
c'est pourquoi j'aime bien la rue de la
gaîté moi parce qu'à son nom déjà
il ya des mamans mais ensuite les
sex-shops voilà oui moi je me cherchais
qu'il y ait une suite des radiateurs
fascine toujours
c'est l'inventivité humaine pour les
jouets du plaisir dix on a pensé aller
jouer du plaisir c'est à dire que le
dire on va dans un endroit examine le
godemiché lumineux wells était honorée
par faire tomber de michel minutes
ensuite pour les gens qui adorent le
disent pas qu'ils avaient une belle
niche est en forme le fond un pour les
filles qui aiment les pieds chez les
filles paraît-il qui prennent leur pied
mais aussi des pièges qu'ils avaient le
godemiché en forme de pied il ya détruit
et moi je te dire alors à hambourg donc
pour la dernière vague lundi j'ai pu
emballer dans une section ça va aller
voir un peu gênant c'est laid c'est là
que les drames de la notoriété safari
dans cimpor actuellement de nouvelles de
terrain
mais est donc enfin j'ai plein d'idées
mais alors comme entre temps j'en avais
été réduite au bouquin écomusée pour me
regarder comme sur les choses de la vie
j'ai trouvé ça nettement moins bien la
jci linge ou non
calypso la sexualité des chinois que
j'avais vu la taiwan le conseiller culte
elle m'avait refilé ou quand même jeu
complet maître caezar chez moi par
exemple isabelle pour le garçon ainsi
disent que consentent fils comme ça cela
ce week-end et qui est en jade est alors
le dragon vachement bien sculpté par un
team très agréable la glace et j'ai
acheté aussi à taiwan et une petite
noire
nous avons aussi sculpté une loi une
vraie noir qu'elle est en entière avec
sa note temps et tout vernis sculpté
finement comme pour les chinois nous
avons la petite dame avec à la seconde
comme les danseuses indiennes à 6 déjà
il est très souple
le garçon qui est monté sur sa cuisse et
qui parle de l'alu empilés dans
l'oreille
c'est pas un mythe non non jamais c'est
vachement d'abord et deuxièmement ça
c'est quand même à une façon de raconter
une civilisation une société
extraordinaire ce que tu vois tu vas en
bout vous pouvez même ici dans un
sex-shop c'est des engins toujours plus
gros avec des moteurs et à sauver
l'univers et bien voilà c'est dit
je me suis acheté le bras de référence
qui s'appelle je crois atlantica
universaliste je me situe peut-être ça
commence et un bouvier toi sérieux ça
commence à l'antiquité grecque
j'arrive à l'époque moderne on vas tu te
rends compte que je suis sophistique
incroyablement tu apprendras visage
c'est du temps des grecs aux ja melesse
était incertain vous y verrez m les
filles les chairs européenne avait fait
le tour ensuite commence
les épouses et amis avaient les vaches
sk pas vers qui sort une compilation de
tous les textes jusqu'à l'os oui il
parle d'un mésopotamiens il ya quarante
cinq siècles cette nuit la neige mais
pas les bienvenus
le matin en se levant une vache c'est
une bonne initiative et sado masochisme
rien 20 18e but comme trajet littéraires
culturelles mais tu penses bien quand il
a commencé à se taper sur le cul à
l'écouté mais alors si en france et
c'est bien ce que je trouve faisant pas
du tout il a mené les enfants revint tu
vois les empereurs romains tuba de cette
esthétique avant la lettre
cette fois son service comment ça
s'appelle un bus annemasse et non pas du
tout étonnant vu la vie des douze césars
et donc ne savent pas mais c'est quand
même une super mais le côté quand lé
talent ou les trucs qui l'obligé un
groupe humain se fustiger et à baiser
ensemble il faisait des tableaux
érotiques dans son jardin à capri île de
capri contemporain du christ et l
empereur pendant que triste effet christ
dans à capri sont ils son fief et lors
qu'elle le soit il fallait qu'il y ait
dans les jardins des groupes humains en
train de faire des faits elle aurait on
a utilisé le terme de genre corner
justement des fellations de sodomies et
des accouplements de toute simple avec
des animaux zatara et devait-il en
pleine forme et en pleine action quand
le jeu conte d'hiver se promener dans
son jardin par robin c'est du cinéma
pendant et en même temps il était lui
cruauté terrible et les envoyer et à
partir du moment où tu organises départ
tout d'une part et qui m'énerve quand
que tu jettes des gens sur les rochers
alors j avais
résoudre à en faire mystère avait dit il
a dit donc je peux pas me garder pour
moi parce que je le début il va dire
vraiment pour chats chier dessus
fm est très fort
non
je
[Musique]
il
oh
[Musique]
mais
moi
bonsoir ça va s'effectuer sous la griffe
de béziers avant que l'intéressé avait
dit c'est merveilleux non non je n'ai
ana lucia y habiter tout doux à madrid
ah bon si toi aussi peur là il siffle
pas tu chantes aussi mais tu y es tu
siffles oui c'est d'après comment de
sifflet de tout péter
intégrant la fission pour siffler je
vais toujours sifflé à cet été chez toi
oui j'ai dû aller à l'école à siffler il
donnait un concert à ma famille il ya
sifflé avant il y alors là non
une émission de radio à radio m'a dit je
fais ma première sortie les gens vendent
à la science ont dû siffler une petite
fille il ya causé beaucoup impression
c'est à partir de là qu'ils m'ont appelé
pour les filmer tout ça c'est fait
il fait sans tenter quelques films mais
en france et l'avenir c'est pour l'année
prochaine pour le lyonnais
non c'est pas professionnel pour le
front national était révisionniste plus
prochain comment la connaissez
en fait là encore encore une fois ce
gentil parfois oui bien je dors
maintenant une banque a donné sa main et
c'est toi qui sifflaient dans les films
de morricone et tout ça voilà
mais il y en a des films par simple
belle des faits des savants diamant de
très spécial est propre à beaucoup de
sifflet final de tout content c'est pas
qu'on s'appelle là il y en a beaucoup
des fêtes
mais maintenant je le registre une disco
qui est fait des arrangements et
spéciale il ya eu beaucoup de sifflets
pas beaucoup des films ou six ans un des
trucs de morricone sait comment savoir
bon c'est pas tout mais c'est
extraordinaire parce que moi quand je
fais comme ça chez comme ça avec lui
avec les airs mais j'utilise pas les
lèvres
oui c'est selon la la les besoins si je
dessine des aiguilles des graveurs des
salons les diamants oui c'est là c'est
michel instruments quoi c'est un rôle
extrêmement précis il faut donner des
noix en c1 l'expression les feelings
mons et comme les chanteurs chaque année
un thème différent
moi c'est pareil tu sais tu sais si fait
du classique des choses précise qu'il
faut déplacer que des gas ouais
chacun mais viennent même de flamenco
sur tout mais on préfère un peu la
guitare
il faut trouver quelqu'un
à
le
là
mais nous pas comme à houston
c'est pratique on est frères
thibault
à
[Musique]
where humain qui après new river n'ayez
les coeurs contre nous endurcis car si
pitié de nous aux avait dieu on aura
plutôt de vous merci vous le voyez si
attachés 5 6 ans de la chaire que trop
avons nourri ait les pieds ça a dévoré
pourri et nous les eaux venons cendres
et poudre de notre mal personne ne s'en
riz mais rit et dieu que tous nous
veuille absoudre ça
c'est beau cette rue watt non ouais
c'est vrai que je t'ai porte dauphine
mais je me suis dit c'est pas moi c'est
beau hein quand je vais le plan à
l'envers comme ça je ne la sait très
très bien mais seulement applicable et
c'est qu'ils veulent la détruire la
connerie n'a pas de mémoire
c'est classique mais bien
bon allez j'y vois là des rues waite on
va se balader le soir de match s c'est
comme le seul endroit où il n'y a pas un
flic depuis une heure
quoi tu es le seul endroit où il n'y a
pas un poulet depuis nous c'est génial
y'a pas de vigipirate mais tu vois la
lumière c'est extraordinaire on dirait
du trône heures tu vois c'est
complètement fou c'est la réalité
ouais c'est beau tu vois des gueules
hurlantes là c'est beau c'est les
grottes de lascaux c'est génial et et
dégoulinures tu peux inventer des mondes
moi j'ai été bon je me faisais chier
dans une pièce de trois mètres sur deux
dans une banlieue qu'était pantin et
engagement mais dans une cour lépreuse
comme celle-là et j'inventais des images
et des volumes à travers ça j'ai grandi
grâce à ça et comme tous les fous avec
ça tu fais un univers tu fais une cité à
lhassa lambeaux du fait du délire et
c'est ça qui est beau le fait de rats
transformer la réalité de marans que si
j'allais arriver sur une plage mais pas
longtemps la marée s'était retirée en
laissant plein de petits ruisseaux voilà
là et les picasso aussi et je regardais
ça et je me disais que finalement
j'aurais pu être dans un avion les mille
mètres d'altitude
j'avais la même impression en étant
debout en regardant une tyrus les voilà
que si j'avais été en avion en train de
s'embrasser fantasme de l'enfance et de
retrouver la recrée la réalité dure et
qui passent en avion à 10 mm au tube
barriques et tu vois les dictateurs qui
veulent des crocodiles qui voit les
éléphants et vitré au fond pas se
prendre pour dieu non plus n'a pas
simplement une vision de l'esprit
passagers d'un avion
exactement et ce boeing jeu le pilote
depuis 51 ans de ma vie
et voilà puis un jour il va se crasher
comme tout le monde elle c'est pas grave
j'espère laissé quelques traces sur
quelques oscillations pense qu est ce
que tu penses que tu as apporté aux dans
l'art parce que la bdc
oui enfin faut pas se prendre la sienne
a plus et non mon apport dans la bande
dessinée c'était une relecture c'est à
dire la mise en page le cadre un cadre
différent qui je le répète les dessins
textes aussi un début de son texte vise
la première bande dessinée sans texte à
l'époque
et puis si on fait de recréer l'image
mais ça venait aussi de mode mais
adolescence de mon amour du cinéma
je suis un fou de l'expressionnisme
allemand les mais qu'ils n'avaient pas
de son à l'époque pas de musique pas de
dialogue parce que c'est un cinéma muet
donc par l'expressionnisme de l'image
avec absolument qui recrée une mise en
page et une mise en place de l'image et
ça m'a servi pour la bande dessinée
parce que j'étais est tributaire comme
tout artiste tu as réussi des choses que
tu prends avant sur des sur les choses
qu'on crée d'autres gens a vendu javier
est donc tu réinvente mois gustave doré
pour moi étonne mais m j'ai fait des
membres décédés dont israël où je
reprends des dessins juste avant de
ricocher si tu es tu as besoin tu
éduques une pyramide où chaque
génération elle ajoute sa pierre renet
beaucoup de dope à l'époque ce que les
gens qu'ils disaient et bd on prenait
alors moi j'ai un problème je me suis
enfilé tout ce qui existe sur la planète
je dis bien absolument tout pendant des
années la seule chose que je n'ai jamais
pris ces de l'acide
or j'étais aux états unis de nombreuses
fois dans des débats dans des
confirmands d'état cela dit ian s je
suis le mec tous les acides du monde se
sont éclatés que mes bd
la seule chose que j'aie jamais pris
puisque je n'aime pas les voyages quand
tu contrôles pas moi j'aime bien me
défoncer la gueule pendant un jour ou
deux et après tout choix au boulot la
star et j'ai eu des conférences aux
états unis où j'expliquais ce que je
viens de te dire il y avait 150 mètres
dans la salle qui concerne traité de
[ __ ] d'enfoirés de fragiles et aux
parce qu'ils n'y croyaient pas jeudi me
taire tous les amis mais dacic des
années 70 autour de la planète ont mis
mes albums
mais bon voilà je te confirme je le sais
je te dis je tout prix sauf ça parce que
j'avais peur je suis très content de ma
rentrée c'est toujours bien dans la vie
quand on peut on rencontre des gens
qu'on a sur lesquels on a tripé ce
qu'elle le dire quoi et je suis très
content de te rencontrer
alors ce poteau c'est génial on dirait
un command ya un truc du colisée au tec
les papiers peints les papiers décoller
et tout c'est fantastique architectural
afl avec les boulons moi je suis un fou
de la tour eiffel ce qui est beau c'est
le mélange de d'architecturé
industrielle absolument mais les
réminiscences corinthiennes c'est
extraordinaire tu vois ce mélange 19e
complètement fou un écran peut-être un
peu plus tard dit est complètement barge
est là dessus tu rêves là tu rêves si
flingue ça c'est débile
tu vois c'est ça le problème par contre
la tôle ondulée ses plus récents essais
nagusa c'est autre chose c'est l'apport
contemporain et a vu les mecs qui sont
collé du papier de sucer tous être des
dessins et tout c'est dingue cette va
bien ce décor ce trou j'aime bien et là
tout coursive là-bas être jolie aussi de
du chemin de ronde avec des scènes
aménagées
oui jérôme mesnager qui tombe
parfaitement bien va lui faire un peu de
pub c'est génial écoute c'est
extraordinaire grotte de lascaux 20e
siècle c'est fabuleux
c'est superbe ça voilà la belle
résultant des choses de ce qu'on vient
de dire tu peux t'inscrire l'aide future
comme des tags et autres dégoulinures ça
passe c'est beau
jusque là tout il ya de la craie là un
petit poêle de marqueurs compagnie tout
mais qu'il a fait une jolie bitton
découpant comme ça beau travail est une
sorte d'énorme tout à l'heure nous n'en
voulons pas c'est extraordinaire ça
c'est la vie c'est extraordinaire
il flotte dessus dans cinq ans c'est
fini c'est l'effet mer ça repart il ya
une trace c'est génial t'as pas malgré
tout l'impression d'être devenu un peu
un ce qu'était la médaille des arts et
lettres non d'être devenu un peu venu en
monuments historiques un peu comme chez
what la rue watt soit je suis un
classique se voit dans la bd et je m'en
fous moi ce qui compte c'est ma vie qui
est à une source d'eau qui est très
belle
une source de rupture à la flotte source
dehors un source de russes
extraordinaire en dominant les mecs des
droits égaux des cellules atomiste
atonie complète vous savez il ya un
picasso a frappé là à oui c'est des bons
et ailleurs cédé c'est pas malin et amis
se sont parfaitement adaptés à la
porosité du matériau un ticket lapierre
espèce de firmes r2c pose de la pierre
d'ailleurs c'est pas du tout c'est pas
du béton ça il s'adapte dessus tout
c'est génial les pochoirs un assez beau
linge à une expo en pleine rue c'est
fantastique toi mon dieu mais qui vient
4h du mat pour faire son truc c'est
quand même génial c'est beau le soir
c'est saint louisienne d'asco
extraordinaires ici c'est que ça regarde
cette chaîne de partout regarder oui
mais il y aura pas le temps qui les
stalagmites et stalactites
il me foutent en l'air dur c'est clair
tu vois ta la flotte qui dégouline
jambes laddh runner tu vas selon les
règles exactement c'est fou
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
oui
je mens
des abeilles toi moi je suis anne avant
j'aurais dérange non non non attendez
méchante mais les conneries pourquoi par
exemple je préfère les rouges de 83 ans
qu'on trouve dans la brousse en cassant
maillot le tarn on la connaît c'est
comment tu peux pas je te donne quand
même un nom est écrit les connais je
vais vous réalisez une petite
performance de 1979
un remake personnes dans cette petite
performance nulle parce que je suis gens
qu'ils n le petit maître liégeois de la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle
artiste de la médiocrité et de la 101
importance comme orb attitude dans ces
petites performances je faisais semblant
de me maquiller avec queue de l'appareil
comme ceux ci oppose et puis je prenais
un peu de concentré de tomate et je
faisais pour essayer de plaire au grand
public une sorte de bouffe de clown un
peu minable mans évidemment parce qu'il
faut pas nécessairement plaire au grand
public demain et hop quand je vais eu
terminé de faire cela je me suis un peu
les mains et avec un jaune d'oeuf du jeu
faisait un petit veille de clown et avec
un petit blanc de jeu faisait un petit
chapeau de clown up minablement mais en
somme c'était surtout pour faire un
hommage à la vasectomie en 1965 j'ai
décidé de ne jamais procréé et en 1970
je me suis fait vasectomie zay la
coupure des canaux déférents pour ne
plus trop crié chat mais pour tourner le
dos
à la suite des générations vous allez me
demander pour quelles raisons pour
toutes les raisons du monde
alors voici sept petits ce petit hommage
la vasectomie
attention attention attention attention
ce n'est pas le vrai et squash
ce n'est pas non plus rien et plus
elle ce n'est pas fini et à faire un
petit tour ça c'est pour faire belge et
voilà voyez c'est ça de l'armée
et
à thé de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu